roger goodell says they expect not
partially full stadiums
not limited capacity oh full stadium
2021 full stadiums coast to coast
all teams full stadiums it's a long way
away
but and and right now you can't really
say we're making progress
because it's kind of gone the wrong way
recently with the pandemic
but as more and more people get
vaccinated i'd like to think by
labor day weekend i god if we don't get
this thing under control by then we
really are
screwed but i think there's reason for
optimism that by the time september
october november december roll around
we'll be in a position where folks can
go to these games
enough people will be vaccinated we'll
be getting closer and closer to
hurt immunity if not already there by
virtue of the vaccinations
and the other dynamics related to
pandemics so hopefully he's right
hopefully the expectations of the nfl
which has access to some of the
best medical minds in the world
hopefully
their prediction will come to fruition
they certainly don't seem afraid to like
you know push the limits a little bit
you know and
i i do think you know last year they
even said at one point in the spring
that
you know they were expecting full
stadium so they're always i don't think
they said that i don't think they ever
said last year that they expected
the stadiums during the 2020 season all
right now uh p pete pete's giving us
fake news there were never reports that
the nfl expected full stadiums
there was optimism that they have gotten
under control by that
the testing methods would be better than
they ended up being it took a long time
to develop
the right kind of testing so you
you you could have confidence that the
virus wasn't going to be
spread around a locker room i mean the
problem was the nfl did a far better job
of limiting the spread of the virus than
the rest of the world did
i remember by the end of the season you
weren't worried about guys spreading it
in the facility what you were worried
about was guys getting it when they left
the facility yeah no you're right that's
that's where we were at yeah
and i mean you know to what you said
mike it seems like we are going in the
right direction to a degree
you know you mean yeah the vaccines herd
immunity all of that seems positive
i also think like you know the
give a crap factor has also gone down a
little bit too
i just do feel like people have kind of
like uh
loosened up don't care or at their wits
end with it a little bit too to where
that's you know causing some
dangerous attitude yeah dangerous so we
don't endorse that no but i i do
i do sense that more now you know then
it's getting nicer out those type of
things so
we'll see but you know i think the great
thing is we'll get a good feel for how
they handle
the draft being outside in cleveland
that hopefully can be a little bit of a
jump off spot to give
everybody more confidence to be a part
of those type of things and
uh i don't know mike i mean what's your
feel like what's your gut tell you you
think that we can be full stadiums week
one
you know in september for nfl's nfl
football
i i think in places like texas and
florida
regardless of what's going on with the
pandemic i think the question is in the
states where politically
it's been more locked down for good
reason yeah because
the the the situation has been serious
continues to be serious it's going to be
a bit of a tougher sell
and i think part of the hope is that the
nfl can speak it into existence
in the states where the local and state
governments may be less inclined to give
the green light to have a full stadium i
think that
is the pressure point to watch going
forward let me make one observation too
you know um and i'm just gonna say this
i'm not i'm not making a political
commentary nothing about this should be
political
the fact that some states have ditched
the mass requirement
has made people in the states where the
mass requirement is still in effect
far less likely to comply that's very
unfortunate
just because texas and alabama or
wherever else is saying you don't have
to wear a mask
you don't live in texas or alabama if
you live in a state that says you have
to wear a mask but
chris i go out on a very limited basis
still i've had one
pfizer shot i'm getting the other one
tomorrow i'm still very careful about
where i go and what i do and i always
wear the mask uh for myself and how to
respect everyone else
and i i'm seeing when i go out and more
and more people yeah
the hell with the mask and it's like
what wait a minute nothing's changed
here in west virginia
there's still a mass mandate but i think
as other states start saying no mask
people think oh what the hell i don't
need to wear it either i i think so yeah
i mean i think a lot of people are
seeing that
it's springtime the weather's gotten
nicer
people are all thinking hey god people
are getting vaccinated the world's
healthier out there
those type of things i i see it too not
that i see anything egregious
but you know i you go down the street a
month ago
and everybody was wearing a mask now i
feel like you could be walking down the
street
and you'll see a few people that you
know they have a mask in their hand or
they got a mask but they're not wearing
it right now because they're outside and
they're just going to try to keep their
distance and do that
you know i mean i i mean i understand
some people are going to do that but
you're right i mean we're not out of
this yet
and you know especially up here in this
area new york new jersey
connecticut you know they've all the
rates have gone up again here so
we'll see i mean we're certainly not out
of this uh but but you know the
vaccinations the amount we're doing
that's all positive and
you know hopefully it will turn the
corner here soon
all right they got the full season in in
2020 which no one expected to happen no
one even the most
optimistic would have never imagined
all games being played now there was
some shuffling that had to be done but
all regular season games played all
postseason
games played capped by a super bowl in
tampa where the buccaneers won
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports